hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 15 video or my
scarecrow video ever you want to think
about it all about the birth of the
Jonathan crane scarecrow it was a lot of
fun meeting his father in this two-part
episode the way I think of it is it's
like the next step in the way Gotham
tells stories previously like the first
half of the season we met like a couple
people's fathers but we really didn't
get to see any of those little kids take
on their villain personas like we got to
see Thomas Eliot as hush but we didn't
get to see any hush related stuff
I feel like this kind of episode is the
writers listening to the fandom we want
to see things that are more like the
comics surprisingly for an episode that
featured the Scarecrow so much there
weren't quite that many Easter eggs at
least not as many as I usually find in
episodes but let's start with top five
moments so just careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet number five fish Mooney finds some
new friends and a lot of people in last
week's episode thought that that person
that bull rushed sure was monster Milad
we really don't know where she's at
right now I think that the show will
answer that it'd be crazy if she was on
like quarto Matty's I feel like that's
an island that they can share on all the
DC TV shows if you're not familiar with
that it's actually an island that was
created by Frank Miller in the story
Dark Knight Returns it's like a port
O'Call for criminals drug traffickers
all the really awful people in the DC
Universe the rape stuff was a little on
the nose but I understand they did it
just a tee up her kicking ass clearly
she's taking over the prison population
she used him to brush back into Gotham
and cause a bunch of trouble for penguin
Falcone everybody else the episode was
all about facing your fear or maybe
living with fear cuz I guess now
Jonathan crane is stuck with his
nightmare for the rest of his life what
do you think that fish Mooney is afraid
of probably just being weak the back
story that she narrated in the first
part of the season was actually false
like she told this big story about her
mother the prostitute it turned out she
was lying clear clearly that dancer
right next to her was her mother but I
think she's just someone who came from
nothing so she's scared to go back to
nothing given her trajectory in this
episode I think she's gonna come
screaming back into Gotham pretty soon
penguin got kicked out at the beginning
of the season he came roaring back
she told Bullock she'd be back I think
she's gonna make good on that promise
speaking of which number four office
romances never work out trust me
did anyone elses ears prick up when
Bullock said that like maybe he was
talking about something that he did in
the past like he had some kind of office
row
and that went really really bad I don't
think he was talking about his
relationship with fish mooney
necessarily because when we had that
flashback for him when we saw his
partner get killed his old partner he
was a lot more like Jim Gordon what do
you think that Bullock's comment means
about Leslie Thompkins in Gordon I think
we're all in the same page Gotham as a
city just eats people's relationships
it's like a goodwill vampire it just
sucks the happiness out of people onto
number three
Batman can't be trip a lot of you told
me you saw like a Batman shaped leaf or
a Batman shaped pattern whatever he fell
down to the ravine I feel like they're
just teasing Batcave if you go based on
the Christopher Nolan trilogy he's about
the right age for finding the Batcave or
falling down into the well that's why
when he was messing with that rock
formation I was like okay is he gonna
fall down the well what's going on
that's something that I feel like it
would be totally okay for the show to do
because there's a huge comic book moment
but it doesn't involve him putting the
cowl on and I think that based on the
contract that Fox has with DC and Warner
Brothers he just he can't put the cowl
on on to number two the birth of the
Scarecrow the timeline was a little
confusing but cranes senior his father
injected him with all the fear talks and
gave him the exact same treatment that
he got the doctor explained at the end
that the physical effects had worn off
but the psychological effects would last
forever so I think that that was the
same case for cranes senior remember
when his dad took the serum for the
first time in the the staircase lit on
fire and he saw his dead wife yelling at
him a couple days later he was still
seeing that vision so I think it was the
same for him you would constantly be
living in a state of fear but the way
cranes senior was talking sounded like
he had conquered his fear so he wasn't
hallucinating things anymore but based
on that last scene it sounds like he was
it's a little bit different from what
happens in the comics usually when
people get dosed with fear toxin it
wears off after a period of time so
presumably a scarecrow tweaks the
formula just a little bit so that it's
not quite so crazy does anybody think
it's weird though how much some of the
storylines and the DC TV shows line up
with each other unintentionally like
arrow has vertigo right now people are
hallucinating just like they're
hallucinating with the fear toxin on
Gotham the writing staff for both those
shows don't have any any overlap like
they don't talk to each other about the
stories that they're writing the same
thing happened during arrow season two
when they did mirakuru and agents of
shield did a Super Soldier Serum story
I just think it's funny the way things
overlap in a meta way unintentionally
and my number one moment the Joker
teaser at the end of the episode I know
there was a lot of confusion about what
that clip was actually about so one it
teased the flank racence that was what
the circus stuff was about the circus
tickets - yes that is the Joker
character that they're setting up I have
no idea how that's gonna play out or
what it's gonna turn into the character
is only being credited as Jerome if you
read Batman I think it's Batman 38 they
tried to tell a joke or origin story in
the comics but originally in the comics
he doesn't really have the traditional
origin story that other characters get
so this is a new thing trying to tell a
history of the Joker Michael Keaton's
first Batman film tried to tell
something of a Joker origin story even
that took some liberties with the comics
so you guys can let me know how you feel
about Gotham twisting the origin story
of the Joker just a little bit all TV
shows are kind of adaptation so you have
to take it with a grain of salt like
okay they're probably gonna change some
stuff from the comics but hopefully
they'll stay as faithful as possible in
the only Grayson character that's listed
on the cast list for the episode is John
Grayson I know in the comics Nightwing
Dick Grayson is a way younger than Bruce
so it's possible that the flying
Grayson's that our dick Grayson's
parents are really young in this episode
as if it's a long time before they're
going to have a son and named him dick
so here's my big question for you guys
if they're able to do this Joker
storyline if they're able to tee this up
who do you want to see them try next
what I'm really hoping is is that the
evil Wayne board members that they've
been teasing end up turning into a court
of owls
I'd really like to seem to a court of
owls storyline oh and I almost made like
this entire video and completely forgot
about it but the moment where the
Riddler meets the penguin it was so much
fun
they threw a bunch of shaded each other
just implying that they're not gonna be
on the best of terms I think once the
Riddler crosses the line and starts
becoming more of a villain then they'll
enter into some sort of arrangement the
enemy of my enemy is my friend
so they'll team up because they hate
someone more than they hate each other
so in related news if you guys didn't
see it they just cast Milo Ventimiglia
as a new character called ogre he's not
someone directly out of the comics but
here's the character description forum
handsome wealthy in seductive the ogre
is a serial killer who has been preying
on the young women of Gotham for nearly
a decade
bring them into his web in confronting
them with a series of tests as he
searches for his perfect mate when the
women failed to live up to his
impossible standard he disposes of them
quickly and viciously so he's a serial
killer looking for love Joker Harley
Quinn style he's looking for his Harley
Quinn one thing I didn't mention though
I'm really hoping that Bullets statement
about office romance has something to do
with the Riddler and Miss Kringle it's
really hard to tell where they're taking
that because she seems like she's slowly
warming up to him but I feel like he is
gonna do something really crazy but with
any luck we'll see like a version of
Harley Quinn like the show's
interpretation without her being the
actual Harley Quinn character they're
kind of pushing that idea of really
twisted relationships with Bullock and
fish Mooney so I feel like they could
totally go there with the Riddler and
Miss Kringle let me know that do you
want to see Miss Kringle get into some
sort of you know villainous sexual
relationship with the Riddler at a
certain point if he's gonna become the
Riddler and turn evil and start doing
evil things do you want to see her go
with him
it's like evil Jerry Maguire I'm gonna
go make some crime who's coming with me
so if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe to get next week's video we're
gonna see the Joker it'll be really
interesting to see what the show's gonna
do with him if they're seating him this
early I'm really interested to see if he
ties in with the finale it could be a
some bigger part to play and for those
that are asking yes I am working on my
agent Carter video I'll get that out
next and then I'll do my Q&A videos for
arrow the flash and then for Spider Man
Marvel I'm gonna try and post all that
stuff before the weekend while you guys
wait for all that stuff to drop you can
click here to catch up on Gotham and you
can click here to catch up on arrow from
last night thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight
you